My naturopathic doctor recently commented that the only scan available that truly identifies
a truer tuber as biologically active in a living cancer cell is a pet scan.
All other scans, including the Pradovo, just detect a mass.
We assume, obviously, if the size is growing, that's an active cancer, but if we've got a
lump that's really staying the same size, there's no way to know if it's a brotic tissue or
cancer or something else.
Do I agree?
The answer that is yes, I do agree, and I'll go even one step further just because it's
showing up as metabolically active on a pet scan doesn't mean it's necessarily growing.
So any living tissue is going to have metabolic activity.
What a pet scan's looking for is that difference in metabolic activity.
Is it highly metabolic that's going to, as they tune their instrument, you know, they're
looking for where there's higher metabolic activity in an area.
So yes, I would totally agree that a pet scan is the only way to show and to scan what
is metabolically active.
Everything else is going to look at a mass.
They can't look at whether it's living tissue, growing tissue, or anything else, but a pet
scan still can't even say that it's growing.
So if you really want to know if there's cancer in other places, a pet scan is really the best
scan.
Now, the reason why a person would choose the Pradovo over a pet scan is simply because of
the radiation issue with a pet scan.
You're getting radiation and you're having to take a sugar dose with a pet scan and some
people are opposed to doing that and understandable.
So you just have to weigh it out what you're really looking for.
If you know you have cancer and you know what's active and you just want to know if you have
cancer somewhere else, doing a Pradovo is the least invasive of those.
And if you haven't had a lot of pet scans, you haven't had a lot of CT scans, then you
know getting a pet scan done is more accurate, I would say, but it comes with it the invasiveness
of the radiation and the invasiveness of having to take the glucose syrup.
So that's where people go against it.
But again, remember all those things, it's the radiation is what's measured and what's
called a rad dose.
The more radiation that you get throughout your lifetime, the more damaging it's going to
be.
So if you're like, all I've got is dental X-rays and maybe some X-rays at my chiropractor
and I got an MRI to diagnose my cancer, I haven't even had a pet scan or CT scan.
But now, you know, I have some bone pain or you have suspect of metastasis, then you
know go ahead and do a pet scan.
If you're simply using the pet scan and doing a test just on a curiosity to see if there's
metabolic activity and things are growing, then I would question that.
Remember, my whole saying about doing an invasive test is you do an invasive test if it's going
to change the way you treat the patient.
So as you as a patient, you would choose to do an invasive test.
If you're going to choose to change the way you treat it, if you're going to go, if you're
saying, I'm just curious if the cancer in my breast is is metabolically active and growing,
I'm not going to do anything different.
But I'm going to keep doing what I'm doing, then I wouldn't do it.
But if it's like, okay, I have this horrible pain in my spine and I want to make sure that
I don't have metastasis to the spine and if I did, I might opt to do radiation or something
because this has really bothered me.
Well then that's a reason to do a pet scan because it may change the way you treat it.